so yeah there's gonna be a lot of
spoilers here and so be mindful the
short version of how this movie koi why
don't you do the honors of recapping the
short version of uh this movie is a
nation in mourning has to deal with
ramifications of an outside party
causing a global conflict it was uh all
about emotional trauma and generational
trauma in a very specific way and
therefore the post-credit scene which
we're about to get into dealing that the
most head-on in phase four was
fascinating but it was about taking on a
mantle and it was different ways of
viewing leadership and it was Revenge
versus Vengeance versus Authority versus
leadership and all of these very very
broad themes with a juxtaposition of
aggressive violence and sensory overload
intermixed with powerful poignant
silence it's it's a lot of movie that
does not explain how we get to the post
credit I'm so used to not spoiling like
I'm so careful that I'm like can I talk
about it like I'm so afraid like I feel
the snipers like Kevin feige's behind me
isn't he you're right nothing away that
was literally the most lawyer I could
have done the plot the color blue
represents
what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here today to talk
about the Black Panther wakanda forever
post credit scene we want to talk about
our emotional response to it why I think
it's probably Marvel's best or at least
one of the best post-credit scenes
they've ever had and of course what this
could mean for the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and joining me today
is koi the genre who is killing it on
the tick tocks lately he's got a solo
review up here on the channel he's
watching it again because we have to do
a live stream spoiler talk this coming
Saturday so ladies and gentlemen leave a
like subscribe click that notification
Bell get notified when our spoiler talk
is uh going live so I'm just gonna give
you guys the the briefest version of the
book on forever ending of how it went
down so we could talk about the
post-credits scene and hopefully this
just sounds very natural as I go into it
alright so at the end of the movie after
the conflict with wakanda and the people
of talocon has been put to rest at least
so it seems sure he goes to visit Nokia
and Haiti where Nokia has been residing
but before the credits roll shuri is
readying herself to let go at this time
of grief and burn t'challa's white robes
on the beach do it alone something that
she refused to do earlier in the film in
the mid-credits scene however Nokia
joined shuri on the beach but she has a
kid with her who we end up learning is
t'challa's son who goes by the name to
Saint but whose real name is actually
also t'challa making him Prince t'challa
now before we dive into the details of
this post-credits scene I just gotta say
in that ending itself just like before
the credits start rolling before the
mid-credits scene I love the way they
captured it because when she's on the
beach and then she closes her eyes and
it's just silence you could feel the
waves it feels truly mournful and
sorrowful mirroring the opening MCU
credits which is my favorite I think
remix of what that world is like the the
movie opens with just a Chadwick tribute
and the opening MCU credits were set to
silence or set to win basically and then
the the wind we hear at the very end of
the film so it bookends the film and I
totally agree that was such a powerful
remorseful moment but I also love that
the last bit of levity we had before
that was her being like I've got to go
do something first and then it gives you
the three things she might be doing like
I love that it was like it cuts to the
ceremony that mbaku was taking over it
cuts to harass it gives you like oh I
bet she's doing that and then what she's
actually doing is this and I was really
impressed that I was like oh she's oh
like they actually got me and then it
was the most sad possible [ __ ] ending
which was great in the mid-credits scene
itself what I love so much of why I
think it's one of the best mid-credit
scenes in in any of Marvel is because
the movie honestly could have just ended
right there with shuri crying letting go
like getting to the stage of grief of
acceptance because acceptance doesn't
mean like I'm happy acceptance is I'm
ready to move on now I'm ready to let go
as hard as it is I'll never forget you
you'll always be in my memories you'll
always be with me but that doesn't mean
that I have to just be in Anger anymore
you know the four prior stages to
acceptance of grief so it could have
ended right there and what I love about
that new credit scene is that feels like
an epilogue and or the real ending of
the film most of the time these mid
credit scenes or post-credit scenes
purely feel like a setup for the future
they feel like a commercial is what I'm
getting at and a lot of times that
commercial is awesome and exciting I
love them but it's a commercial it is
mainly just a commercial like a lot of
times the movies don't need that this
one felt like it really completed the
film it completed the actual story for
it and gave a resolve it's the exact
opposite of how I felt about the Moon
Knight post credit sure in that the Moon
Knight post-credit is literally the same
format as this where it's the scene ends
the scene continues then it really ends
but in Moon night it felt like it
undercut the ending of the first one
whereas this one it felt like it
bolstered the entire film this is just
an emotional Landing this is a a
continuation of a scene that felt like
like you said could have ended it's
resolve versus like gotcha and it didn't
feel I don't know cliche yeah because it
ends with shuri in pain but the
post-credits scene gives hope and joy
true happiness for the first time like
as as heartbreaking as as tearful as it
is like man a lot of people were I've
never seen some people cry at a mid
credit scene before hey it tells you
like what Nokia why she really wasn't
there the whole time it gives a real
explanation because you know Washi
explains that yeah he was my everything
to Okoye that she couldn't be there for
present for any of this because it was
too painful for for her you find out
there was actually a deeper reasoning
that involved t'challa and why Sween
raimondo was okay with that like I love
that that one line gave us closure for
raimonda's Arc and her experience and we
it also gave us a moment of realizing
that you know Angela Bassett got to meet
her grandchild like that was a beautiful
moment even dialogue and I don't know
who this boy is but I swear because she
has what they reveal is that Nakia had a
son with t'challa so basically instead
of dealing with the pressure of being
the son of t'challa instead of dealing
with the pressure of being the assumed
ruler of an entire nation and seeing
what that had done to t'challa they have
him be raised in Haiti and I love this
name choice I really love and full
credit to John basically this character
is the prince t'challa which to me is
this beautiful message of rebirth that
the entire phase four has been about the
phase four experience has been morning
therapy going through the processes of
grief and then rebirth and the reason
this is a post-credit scene that I think
sings higher than most is you get this
great tease with one name much like a
secret identity and then you reveal the
true name the hero the moment and that's
true rebirth we see King t'challa in Him
and then we hear he's Prince t'challa
son of King t'challa and you get rebirth
in real time you get the experience of
shuri having this revelatory moment and
seeing her brother and someone else
seeing her her pride and her sorrow and
her Joy all of that conveyed in once and
we're having that emotional experience
because of our connection to the actor
chapter Boseman and the character of
t'challa call this in 30 seconds oh my
God this kid this kid looks like genius
it looks like incredible like I was like
is that Chadwick boseman's kid because
he he looks so much like like him that I
was like the second you see him and
you're like oh that's to Charles tell us
all yeah every second you see him yeah
his smile the way is like his face
lights up feels like when Chadwick had
that like the presence he's the presence
of Bozeman which is incredible you
weren't specifying why we're recording
John I got excited about it
John is because he goes by a name but is
real name is t'challa but the name that
he goes by the Haitian name is Toussaint
and John was saying that he thinks it's
uh in tribute to to Sante who was a
Haitian General and a prominent leader
of the Haitian revolution so you know I
feel like John's probably correct about
that and that's so genius to have the
both of his names have resonance like I
love my name and I think a unique name
really shapes who you are as a person so
I love that he got to have a name that
symbolizes something in Haiti as well as
a name that is part of his identity
because t'challa identifying as the king
of wakanda as well as the Black Panther
as well as all these things I feel like
this already gives that kid a lot of
that like a name has power I loved the
way how Leticia writes performance in
that moment is reacting to him because
in the ending she's so just heartbroken
and Shadow like this is so painful for
her and then she's got a different kind
of melancholic Joy there yeah like that
when she is she seems so genuinely happy
to be interacting with this boy and it
gives her hope for the future and then
on top of that too you know it does set
up the possibility or the likelihood of
we will have to teach us so everyone was
like recast the child we will have a
t'challa in the future and it will be in
the form of this boy when he's probably
grown up now I'm hearing a lot of people
speculate maybe they'll do some type of
time Jump or some Secret Wars thing that
will lead to him just being older or
something like that what do you think is
going to happen here with the future of
this boy I think he's going to be a
young Avenger I think that he's only a
little younger than the well I mean the
Young Avengers are kind of a huge swath
of Ages right now if you look at them
but if you look at the Young Avengers so
far the swath of Ages is pretty crazy
like Eli Bradley and Falcon the Winter
Soldier the grandson who we are getting
that actor back in the upcoming Captain
America four Eli Bradley is like I don't
know 12 13. and this kid looks like he's
probably like eight or nine and then
you've got people as old as Kate Bishop
who's like grown anyway you've got
you've got like a 10-year span So Young
Avengers I think allows for flexibility
I wouldn't age him up it feels like an
odd thing to to play with with someone
going through rebirth like he's already
representing a rebirth of t'challa I
think aging him up would feel kind of
like soft it'd feel like a an Easy
Choice instead of like letting him grow
as I want to see the Journey of when
that boy has to go back to wakanda or go
to wakanda for the first time yeah and
has to deal with all the things that
Nokia and t'challa were worried about
him having to deal with you know his
innocence and his Joy juxtaposing
Michael B Jordan's Vengeance like he
went to wakanda and he went as I'm gonna
take over things using this I'd love to
see him go and have that sense of awe
and wonder but the way that boy
delivered um I'm playing God of War
again boy uh the way the way that little
boy delivered that line of when he says
my name is tacha I forget exactly what
that line is but the way he says it
there is such a demonstration of
strength responsibility and acceptance
in it it's not like some cute kid actor
being like I'm you know do that presence
you could feel the setup of the future
with this kid based off of his delivery
of he is priming himself mentally and
emotionally to go to wakanda one day it
hit me really hard in real life my
experience of how important it is to
talk about death With Children yeah like
I had a moment of I love how she has
addressed that his father is gone with a
sense of joy and pride like he wasn't
sad talking about t'challa she was proud
of his father when they said Baba it
felt like a moment for him not like oh
and I feel like a lot of people just
talk about death so sadly and lost so
sadly it was really an impactful moment
for me as a human to be like death is
inevitable and death is a part of our
experience so we need to address things
in a way that it doesn't [ __ ] us and
I really love how this is all I'm like
this is a 30 second scene like this
scene is not long and we're like this
riveted by it yeah it's I I thought it
was like just the more I talk about it
the more it moves up I'm having motions
right now remembering the emotions I had
that is possibly my favorite because
yeah it's not as exciting as like we're
starting an Avengers Initiative or some
[ __ ] like that right it's not as
exciting as that because you're not
gonna be like you know when it's done I
think in terms of hitting you in the
fields hitting you in the heart and
Landing an emotional beat to feel like
the true button on the film that is why
I rank it so high the emotion was
different because there was that blend
of melancholy and hope it's a really
beautiful emotional resonance it leaves
you with well it's also the playing on
something real life with the passing of
Chadwick Boseman you know so it does
feel like more than to Charles Legacy
lives on it feels like Chadwick
boseman's Legacy will live on and then
the Chadwick foundation in the credits
not long after like there's a foundation
of arts for him and and you know that's
just to me mirrors what the end of the
movie felt like because obviously his
hands were all over it and there's that
moment where uh Angela Bassett talks
about uh his hand on her shoulder uh and
that's something that they kept
referring to on set like Ryan coogler
talked about when he was film filming he
felt Chadwick's hand in his shoulder and
like the fact that they were using
things of their real life experiences
and art that's what art is four is to is
to like process emotion I love that this
post-credits scene much like them using
Chadwick's hand is a processing of
emotion and I think that's really
cathartic for both the audience the
creators the filmmakers the experience
of how important black panther is two
people how much more than just a
character he is to an entire people and
how this child seems to understand in
this portrayal like I don't know the
child but in this portrayal the weight
of that yes yeah I don't know any Marvel
postcardism where you would talk like
this about it so that's why it's my
favorite I think it's a uniquely
emotional experience and I don't think
that's going to be for everyone because
I think people go to these movies for
different reasons I think wakanda
forever won't be for everyone oh
definitely not I'm avoiding the Rotten
Tomatoes score I I don't care to argue
with people I know how much this movie
hit me and I don't want to deal with
just I'm like half of me doesn't want to
do a spoiler talk because I'm like I
just don't want to deal with the people
coming in and yelling with me and I'm
like all right I understand what I do so
yeah yeah I'm going to do it but I don't
really want to do it I left the Press
screening and stood outside by myself
before I filmed anything so I wanted to
process it anyway I thought it was a
beautiful movie and I thought the
post-credit scene was very beautiful
very impactful so yeah guys what'd you
guys think about it leave your thoughts
down below what do you think it means
for the future subscribe click that Bell
leave a like like I wanted to shoot for
10. we shot for 20. that's what we do
that's what we do what we do we like
talking I mean with the three hour
editing session course that's why I'm
here all right guys see you soon
[Music]